well what is the spending review the key
thing to note here is
it's not quite like a budget and why
well
in a budget you're talking about pretty
much everything the government
spends its money on or earns money from
so these two bars show you the total
amount of money coming into the
government so receipts taxes
mostly and that other bar over there
that is spending so expenditure all the
money that's that it's spent on if you
look kind of
closely at the difference between these
two bars where you can probably see it
can't you
this bar here isn't quite as high as
that bar it means we're not bringing in
enough taxes to pay for all that
spending and the gap between those two
lines there
is around 55 billion pounds or at least
it was back in march the last time the
government
looked at this and one of the things
we're going to learn is just how much
bigger
that gap has gone because this is the
first time we've had an update in
official forecasts
since march that might be the big story
in a way just the size
of that hole and what's happening to the
economy but we'll also focus
on what's happening to this bar here and
i want to just underline
it's not all of that bar we're really
talking about it's a particular bit we
can actually break it down
uh into two parts two pots the
government spends money on the bottom
bit
is called annually managed expenditure
that's stuff like welfare debt interest
the kind of stuff they can't really
control
on a year-to-year basis that's not
really the focus here the real focus is
that light blue bit
departmental expenditure that's really
what this spending review is about
spending in departments and let me just
break down that 411 so you have a sense
of what i mean here so that line there's
411 which departments are we talking
about well health
most notably the biggest of all and
we're likely to see more spending
on health that number could go up uh
education they've already got our
spending
plan for three years but we could even
see more money uh for them too
you've got the home office that's
spending on policing and so on you've
got defense they're getting a three-year
extra allowance of money for defense
then you've got other things so
international development do we see
international development uh carter
indeed frozen that's one suggestion
uh that may come out of this uh then
devolved administration say money to
scotland
northern ireland and wales and then
other an investment and the reason
investment is important is we probably
like to hear
a lot about leveling up about
infrastructure spending on all of that
stuff
what we may hear about as well is public
sector pay there may will be a freeze
for some departments when it comes to
their pay why does that matter why do
the treasury think is justified well
look at this line here this shows you
the average public sector pay and how
much is increasing on an annual basis
and you can see
it's been going up a bit it's up to
around four percent uh at the moment now
compare that
to the private sector and it's a very
different story going up in lockstep and
then falling
dramatically during this pandemic and
the point that chancellor is going to
make
is that maybe the public sector may need
to take a bit of a freeze in their pay
because of the gap between those two
lines